today was jen saki's last day as white
house press secretary she's likely
headed for a liberal safe haven of msnbc
and in her honor let's circle back to
her most cringe-worthy moments
why is the administration flying
thousands of migrants from the border to
florida and new york in the middle of
the night
uh well i'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night president biden ever
been to the southern border
in his life yes i will have to get look
back in my history books in terms of
specific conversations i'd refer you to
the state department they would have
more specifics i would send you to dhs
for any more specifics is there going to
be a softer i guess approach in dealing
with um senator manchin i would doubt
he's a a withering flower on the side of
the road i'm happy to circle back with
our team on that specific report circle
back circle back circle back circle back
i hate to disappoint conservative
twitter but i am going to circle back
wow that was liberating um so
since we're running a little short on
time i think it would be nice if we all
maybe helped her
with the new name of her new show since
it hasn't been announced yet my pick of
course is sake's
world
judge jockey prime
time um
how about uh
make it all up by jen zach i like it i
like it oh
uh sake bomb
and
can i just say something okay two people
who i love dearly uh dana and kaylee who
were press secretaries have done a great
job uh changing their career into
television careers so i think she can do
a good job and i think we should wish
her well yeah but you just
said bomb
never want to
[Laughter]
i think it's very easy to be a press
secretary for a democratic president
right right it's a fan club when you get
into the briefing room it's very
difficult to be a republican press
secretary because they're just a bunch
of vipers who want your throat with that
said she did a decent job there's been
worse let's put it that way but i think
she got out at the right time and it
tells me she's getting out now that
means hunter's about to
get indicted because she doesn't want to
be at the podium when that happens plus
she's leaving at the perfect time this
is as worse as it gets for joe the
market's tanking you got record high gas
prices and people can't get baby formula
she's had it yeah do you guys know
remember when you graduated high school
and in the yearbook you had like your
will section or whatever where you could
leave things to other people so in the
reverse i leave for her i bless upon her
for her new show the gifts of
transparency a commitment to truth and
facts um and to answer your question in
terms of the names of the show then i
would just quote her back to herself and
i would name it actions speak louder
than words can i say
yeah you're the judge go right ahead
she was very effective at her job
i agree
all right she was didn't agree with her
she was affected yeah and that was
effective one more thing is up next
i want i'm brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now